شيعه سكان مدينه السليمانيه باقليم
كردستان العراق ضحايا الانفجار الذي هز
المدينه قبل يومين نتيجته انفجار منظومه
غازيه في احد المباني المدينه
في مقتل 15 شخصا من سكان المبنى واصابه
اثنا عشر اخرين بجروح متفاوته
يبدو انك امير تقف بالقرب هذا المنازل
التي تضررت من هذا الانفجار
بالضبط هذا المكان هو حي كازيوه شرقي
مدينه السليمانيه حيث المبنى الذي انفجر
بالكامل كما تظهر الصوره هنا هذا هو مكان
المبنى الذي
تفجر وتذمر بالكامل حتى انه الحق اضرار
جسيمه كما تظهر الصوره همم في المبنى
الملاصق له تماما وذلك الذي همم الى همم
الشمال منه وبالتالي هذا هذه الصوره تظهر
مدى وقوه هذاك الانفجار الكبير الذي همم
تردد صداه في ارجاء هذه المنطقه حسب شهود
ايام حتى
المرء يقول ان المدينه باكملها سمعت ذلك
الصوت الكبير حتى الان همم الاحصائيه
الاخيره لمستشفى همم السليمانيه تقول ان
عدد القتلى هو خمسه عشر وان هناك اثنا عشر
جريحا جراء هذا الانفجار الكبير الضحايا
هم من سكان هذا المبنى الذي تدمر بالكامل
وايضا من سكان المبني المبنى الملاصق له
وذلك الذي وذاك الذي يقع الى جانبه همم
لكن تبدو الصوره هنا ان الشضايا هذا
الانفجار كانت قويه جدا وانها همم ذهبت
الى عده عشرات الامطار من موقع التفجير
هذا التفجير حسب الشرطه هنا في السليمانيه
كان بسبب خلل في منظومه الغاز المعتمده في
معظم او في كثير من من المنازل هنا في
مدينه السليمانيه المنظومه الغازيه التي
تعتمد للتدفئه خصوصا في و و نحن دخلنا تصل
الشتاء الذي تشتهر به السليمانيه من حيث
البروده وسقوط الثلوج وبالتالي هذه
المنظومه حسب السكان هنا تبدو اقل تكلفه
من المنظمات الاخرى سواء النفطيه
والكهربائيه وبالتالي العديد من هؤلاء
يعتمدون على هذه المنظمات لكن الماخذ حتى
الان هنا يبدو ان الجميع متفق هنا من
السكان اقصد ان الحكومه هي ربما عليها ان
تشدد من اجراءات همم بناء هذه المنظمات
الغازيه والاشراف عليها وعمليات الصيانه
من قبل همم
حتى همم
وقوع حوادث مثل هذه التي هي بالفعل تشهد
تعاطفا كبيرا من عموم العراق همم ليس فقط
من مدينه السليمانيه